Welcome to our YouTube video on the
ethical hacker road map 2024 in today's
digital age cyber security is more
critical than ever with the ever
revolving threat landscape ethical
hackers play a pivotal role in
safeguarding our digital world let's
dive into the facts and figures that
make this topic not just interesting but
essential so moving to the introduction
cyber crime is expected to cost the
world dollar $10.5 trillion annually by
2025 making it one of the most lucrative
criminal activities in history the
demand for ethical hacking is
skyrocketing with 3.5 million unfilled
cyber security jobs and the average
salary of a certified ethical hacker in
the United States is approximately
$997,000 per year and it's consistently
one of the highest paying it
certifications now let's explore the
road map that will guide you to become
an ethical hacker in 2024 and before
that if you are inspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice the course is designed
to accommodate a diverse range of
Learners and this course requires just a
bachelor's degree with a 50% average and
no prior programming experience and
OnePlus year of work experience is
preferred and for more details you can
use the link mentioned in the
description box below and if these are
the types of videos you would like to
watch then hit the Subscribe button like
and press on the Bell icon to never miss
on future content so stay tuned with us
until the end of this video and don't
forget to register your opinion in the
comment section below now starting with
what is ethical hacking ethical hacking
often referred to as whad hacking or
penetration testing is a cyber security
practice in which individuals known as
ethical hackers or penetration testers
legally and responsibly attempt to
uncover vulnerabilities and weaknesses
in computer systems networks
applications and other digital
infrastructure the primary goal of
ethical hacking is to identify and
resolve security flows before malicious
hackers can exploit them and now we'll
see the essential skills for ethical
hacker certainly hear a list of
essential skills for an ethical hacker
starting with strong understanding of
networking that is ethical hackers need
to have a deep understanding of
networking protocols how data travels
across networks and the vulnerabilities
associated with different network
configurations number two programming
and scripting Proficiency in programming
languages like python C C++ and
scripting languages is crucial for
writing custom exploits and tools and
the next is cyber security fundamentals
a solid grasp of basic cyber security
Concepts including threats
vulnerabilities risk management and
security principles is fundamental now
coming to next that is operating system
familiar with various operating systems
including Windows Linux and Unix is
essential for understanding their
vulnerabilities and security
configurations then comes the web
application security knowledge of web
Technologies web application
vulnerabilities such as SQL injection
cross scripting and security best
practices for web development and then
comes the penetration testing tools
Proficiency in tools like meta sploit
nmap wi shark bub suit and other
penetration testing tools used to assess
system
vulnerabilities and then we have
cryptography understanding of encryption
decryption cryptographic algorithms and
their role in securing data and then
there is wireless security expertise in
wireless network security including
Wi-Fi encryption protocols and
vulnerabilities and then we have
security compliance and standards
knowledge of security standards and
compliance regulations such as PCI DSS
HIPAA and gdpr and the next skill is in
inent response being prepared to handle
security incidents and breaches
effectively including forensics and
Analysis understanding of social
engineering tactics used by attackers to
manipulate individuals into revealing
confidential information and then comes
ethical mindset an ethical hacker must
adhere to a strong code of ethics and
prioritize responsible disclosure when
vulnerabilities are found and now we
will move to ethical hacker road map
2024 we'll start with step one that is
build a strong Foundation building a
strong Foundation is crucial in the
journey to become an ethical hacker
start with a deep understanding of
computer science mastering the basics of
Hardware software and networks
familiarize yourself with operating
systems and their functionalities
entry-level certifications like coma A+
and network plus are your Stepping
Stones ensuring you grasp The Core
Concepts of ID a strong Foundation forms
the Bedrock upon which you will build
your ethical hacking skills and
knowledge and then comes step two learn
programming learning programming is a
gateway to unlocking Endless
Possibilities in the Digital World start
by understanding the basics of coding
logic and SX explore languages like
python known for its Simplicity or
JavaScript for web development practice
regularly work on real projects and seek
online tutorials and courses Embrace
problem solving and debugging and
gradually you will Master the art of
programming opening doors to a world of
software development and Innovation now
moving to the step three that is
understand cyber security Basics
understand cyber security Basics is
crucial for any aspiring ethical hacker
it involves comprehending the core
principles of protecting digital systems
and data key Concepts include
identifying threats vulnerabilities and
the importance of risk management
certification programs like comp
Security Plus can provide an entry point
into this realm these Basics form the
foundation for ethical hacking enabling
individuals to recognize and combat
security weaknesses making the digital
world safer and then comes the step four
that is dive into ethical hacking dive
into ethical hacking is a critical step
on the journey to becoming a skilled
ethical hacker during this phase you
will focus on horning your penetration
testing skills and mastering the art of
ethical hacking the certified ethical
hacker certification will be your
companion providing you with the
knowledge and tools to identify
vulnerabilities and secure systems you
will explore real world scenarios test
networks and learn to think like a
hacker while maintaining ethical
standards
this stage prepares you to safeguard
digital Landscapes effectively and then
comes step five that is continue
learning continuing learning in ethical
hacking is essential the cyber security
landscape evolves rapidly so staying up
to date is a must explore Advance
certifications like cissp and certified
ethical hacker C to deepen your
knowledge follow industry news blogs and
research to remain informed about
emerging threats join ethical hacking
communities attend conferences and
engage in ongoing practice to hornn your
skills remember continuous learning
keeps you at the Forefront of cyber
security and ensures you will well
prepared to protect digital assets and
now we'll move to the step six that is
gain practical experience gaining
practical experience in ethical hacking
is crucial for horning your skills
participate in Capture the Flag
competitions CDF where you can solve
real world challenges and learn to think
like a hacker explore Hands-On labs and
exercises that allow you to practice
various hacking techniques in a
controlled environment engage with
ethical hacking communities share
knowledge and collaborate on projects to
build a strong practical foundation in
cyber security and then comes the step
seven seek employment to seek employment
as an ethical hacker craft a resume
highlighting your skills certifications
and experience look for opportunities in
Industries such as Finance Healthcare
and tech companies where cyber security
is Paramount network with Professionals
in the field explore job boards and
leverage online platforms ethical ERS
are in high demand so be proactive in
your job search and showcase your
commitment to safeguarding digital
assets and then comes the step eight
keep evolving keep evolving the world of
ethical hacking is constantly changing
to stay at the Forefront always be
curious Embrace new technologies and
adapt to emerging threats regularly
update your skills an Advan
certifications and network with fellow
hackers remember the cyber security
landscape evolves and so should you stay
ethical committed and dedicated to
safeguarding the digital realm and now
mve to the job roles and average salary
so the first job role for an ethical eor
is security analyst and the average
salary in United States is
$150,000 perom and in India it's 11
lakhs perom and then comes the
penetration testem and its average
salary in United States is
$145,000 perom and in India it's 13
lakhs perom and then comes security
consultant its average salary in United
States is
$120,000 perom and in India it's 10
lakhs perom and then comes security
engineer its average salary in United
States is
$156,000 perom and in India it's 8 lakhs
perom and then comes the incident
respond its average salary in United
States is $15,000 perom and in India
it's 7 lakhs perom and now moving to the
companies hiring cyber Security
Professionals or ethical hackers so the
companies are Amazon aseno Google Apple
and Intel so these are the topmost
companies and there are tons of
companies that hire ethical hackers so
in conclusion the ethical hacker road
map for 2024 is your key to a promising
and rewarding career in cyber security
as the digital realm expands so do the
threats and ethical hackers are the
Frontline Defenders Embrace this journey
and you will not only have a secure
future but also the opportunity to be
part of something bigger protecting the
digital world from malicious intent and
this was all for this tutorial hope you
guys found it informative and helpful
and if you're an aspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certification from prestigious
University and in collaboration with
leading expert to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
learns Advanced executive program in
cyber security in collaboration with
npci should be your right choice and
with this program you can transform your
career in 6 months that is for India
specific region only and this course
provides a high engagement learning
experience with real world applications
and is designed for individuals who want
to start a new more fulfilling career
and if you like this session then like
share and subscribe if you have any
questions you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs and in
cuttingedge domains including data
science cloud computing cyber security
AI machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn ner up and get certified
click
here